why would you argue that bannon giving
him
advice that you would presume which is
to be more trump-like
and to be militant is something that
would serve donald trump and i ask you
this because as you know there's so many
in the republican establishment
say that is not what he should be doing
he should be you know
calming down a little bit trying to
reduce some of
the drama so that he can attract people
in the middle of the political spectrum
i mean as you probably know i think
donald trump's deterred tornado but i
also understand that he has no capacity
whatsoever to control himself and be the
sort of
stayed politician that so many people
want him to be i mean reince priebus
isn't going to convince him to become
mitt romney and trump doesn't want to
become mitt romney i'm not sure he
should want to become mitt romney so
telling him to double down
is not necessarily terrible strategy if
he's going to go down he's going to go
down being trump
and i think that's probably what steve
bannon is telling him to do
a what tornado a turd tornado
what is that well it's like a shark nato
except with poop
okay all right that's not quite what i
expected but okay
uh you're now with